hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to five nights at
Freddy's help-wanted VR I am a brave boy
I mean I'm a brave man I am a brave man
not a boy I'll punch it what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] wait a minute am I
am i I swear to God I saw a face behind
that bunny like on the wall back there
no no it's the way the texture is I'm
sorry okay I'm very sorry about that
for some reason the texture on the wall
behind that bunny back there it's just
so dark and shadow I thought I thought
that was a face holy [ __ ] anyway so
we're going into dark rooms because it
goes from five nights at Freddy's 3 to
dark rooms 2 parts and service to then
repair and I don't want van repair or
night tear so I'm gonna go for dark
rooms whatever this means doing cos it's
kind of plushtrap esque so this might
whoa wait stop plush oh so this is the
mini game oh okay it's the mini game
okay you little [ __ ] wait oh that one
interesting alright get ready to draw
three Oh
nice dick okay you're gonna be okay all
right well let's take a look around the
room first whoa what whoa okay whoa whoa
what what what whoa hey whoa whoa whoa
whoa you I you're not supposed to move
with him what the [ __ ]
where'd you go boy it's all what's that
about what stuff oh my god hey buddy
whoa what the [ __ ]
what's with that what is with that what
the [ __ ] is with this what is that whoa
[ __ ] hey hey hey listen you little [ __ ]
okay you little piece of [ __ ] alright
whatever
come on try me I got a fistful of [ __ ]
and you got a face full of fish
festivals hey where are you running to
little bunny okay alright not a lot of
time poop okay
[ __ ] well I screwed this one up [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah you little piece of [ __ ] all
right you think you can mess with me huh
I got two punchers you think that you
gonna mess with me I don't know what the
[ __ ] that door was about the holy [ __ ]
okay all right okay all right dude let
me cut my finger I heard that
mind you you I got a flash here what
want to whack somebody somebody's about
to get whacked
yeah I see you come on
yeah I got tube here too much light oh
hey buddy
Oh goodbye all right I'll get you this
time Oh
your little piece of [ __ ] you think you
can beat me the answer is you cannot
give me my price I know something
punchable oh wow I thought I'd want to
use already didn't I already kids want
to use your dumb looking oh you're all
so big but that doesn't mean I can't
Boop you on your snoot doing this hey
come on stop that that's my most
sensitive snoot oh you mean this one
abacus I'm eating I'll hurt you real bad
if you do that again
oh you'll hurt me real bad I'm sorry
here it comes
three two one psych out here come boy oh
okay bye
all right cool good great I got that
prize that wasn't so bad
tossing proprietary technology developed
by fazbear entertainment our VR
development teams were able to use
vintage control boards almost like
plug-and-play digitally recreating
performances and personalities from the
past in an instant
right okay well that's great hey do I
get to do the same thing with nightmare
BB cuz that sounds awful I don't want to
do that pulled on triggers stopped on
decks okay all right okay all right oh
you are worse I don't like you okay all
right what's behind the door why don't
you laugh at me you little piece of [ __ ]
You Know Who I am oh yeah that's right
you're not so little
hello you're not so little
you're not as little as I thought you
might be
but I okay are okay okay okay
I love [ __ ] oh [ __ ] who you who you
wanna run that by me again with the
bullets that Hey oh hello hi okay
alright give it more patience you're big
oh uh okay all right I don't like that
don't like this at all Oh
yeah [ __ ] oh my god
okay stop it oh what the [ __ ]
okay whoa okay last one let it go OOP
let it go whoa holy [ __ ] oh my god oh
[ __ ] me whoa whoa whoa whoa okay there
was no need for that ever
boom boom okay all right Jesus Christ
okay all right escalating a little bit
here I don't like it but what it is are
you doing okay all right what plush baby
wait but that's but that's over there
dude
good plush
I don't know what this is even gonna do
it's gonna be the same Oh push and hold
stick pull trigger white 5 until 6 wait
what am i doing wait what am i doing
quit pushing lost what does that even
mean what wait what am i doing what what
am i doing oh oh [ __ ] oh god wait wait
what the [ __ ]
okay wait wait there's a I need this Oh
what the [ __ ] wait hey Oh Oh God
oh my god oh are you kidding me are you
oh my god wait wait wait oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
oh oh god oh god oh [ __ ] me oh [ __ ] me
[ __ ] me oh [ __ ] me holy [ __ ] me I'm
gonna die oh [ __ ]
sorry about that okay I'm not gonna die
I'm not gonna die because I'm just not
oh okay okay okay ladies charts let it
go let it go let it go what a flying
[ __ ] is this [ __ ] about what in the
[ __ ] ass no why what who where and why
who and where and why why what
nothing can are you yeah um yeah about
that yeah about that yeah I don't yeah
about that um yeah I'm not so sure about
that okay so maybe they can only spawn
in specific spots right down there
perfectly understand while they go in
the vents
sometimes there there's a vent over
there something up there okay that was
over to that where was he we're we're
what it I'm not seeing where it was
where was it
Oh God we're is no I don't wanna do
download so so nope
where are you where are you where are
you
wait okay hang on if it's you go in the
vents Oh up there oh [ __ ] okay alright
good good to know okay so they can only
be in so many places at once where where
is it okay that was a bit oh what the
[ __ ]
Oh what the [ __ ] oh okay that's good to
know come on come on come on come on go
go go where was that go somewhere
we're oh god I'm gonna die okay I am
gonna die wait ah I see you okay okay
okay fine yeah this is all fun and games
until this started happening you go if
you're gonna go away I've got some time
where could they be
here there ah area okay
it sounded like above okay ah let it
charge okay I got this just gotta find
him they are there she is there
somewhere okay where i'll see oh we got
a problem
well where where was that where was that
where was that oh [ __ ] me how what
that's open now
ah okay so uh hello
you can only be in so many places at
once it's good to know cuz I just gotta
look back I see you okay I got this
unlock where where was that where is
that what Oh
why ball why ball wait wait wait wait
where are you no no no no I got that one
look my flashlights got cursed [ __ ]
hell
oh my god that's so hard that's so hard
okay you're not gonna get me this time
you little shits yeah you think you can
get from me there's always so many
places you can be I just gotta check all
the places where you could be and that's
eliminating all the possibilities where
oh there you got it okay please tell me
that it's not gonna kill me oh oh what
the [ __ ]
you were just there what you were where
where where ah there you are okay so
there can be multiple ones at any given
time that's what I'm learning about this
okay where where no no no there ah did I
get it
I got it okay I got it okay all right a
little more
there you see there no I don't know I
don't know I don't know I don't know I
know there you are that's okay little
more a little more a little more come on
now gonna make it okay oh no no oh I'm
fine
I want right okay where everything's
good is that an original 1982 lift-away
nyan lard oh my god this is the most
exotic butter I've ever seen
Oh 1982 and its pristine Lithuanian lard
went extinct and in 2004 oh my god oh I
could know myself okay big part my hands
gone we hope you're enjoying the fast
beer virtual experience I am please be
aware that there may be visual artifacts
left behind from the beta testing phase
of development if you see any such
artifacts we recommend that you not
interact with them Oh weed them out
eventually there's no guarantee that
we'll weed them out eventually okay all
right thanks so the visual artifact
being my hands or what what do we what
do we get chatting about over here
what are we should chat about okay fun
to war
hey wait hey wait wait hang on a second
I that down like the dad I don't like
the look of that that's good okay all
right then let's do it
all right fun time foxy it is then huh
okay all right
move thumbstick we excuse me hold
trigger to use flash beacon across the
room no no no no no no no no you don't
understand no I'm good I I don't no no
no no no you're talking Samba Laura [ __ ]
over here and no I I don't want to do
that that's awful that this is funtime
foxy is motion activated Oh for this
reason it's important to keep the room
dark as to not accidentally activate her
wow you have been provided with a flash
beacon use it if you need to get your
bearings and to ensure you don't bump
into anything
Oh however use it as sparingly as
possible
Oh proceed forward to reach the parts
and service room Oh
[Music]
oh [ __ ] me oh no oh no oh no oh no fun
times Russian activated for this reason
it's important to keep the room don't
think I don't know however use it as
sparingly as possible sparing proceed
forward to all God's answer oh hi okay
alright that's great that's wonderful
okay so that's what I'm dealing with
great good to know I'm gonna there's
some okay great nothing can harm me you
know what except my feelings in my brain
and everything all [ __ ] me
[Music]
oh there's something over here this [ __ ]
okay
just look hang on this just oh okay I
don't get it yet how this is all working
oh man oh man all right fine you want to
dance [ __ ] you want dance with me huh
you think I'm afraid of you
what are you kidding me are you kidding
me are you kidding me tink yeah what do
you think about this let's go this way
okay that's too many yes
too many yes too many boy kisses now we
know the limit now we know the limit
okay all right I got this yeah like
clockwork
[Music]
- too soon too soon okay here we are
here we are yes yes yes yes hahaha that
yeah you ain't so bad went from being
the mono monstera sell chips great whoa
oh that's a asbestos did that miss
bestest innit
don't I just need a bag of asbestos I
think that might have said it had
exclusively asbestos which I have a
problem with cuz that's not good for me
alright
so I'm not doing good on coins that's
for damn sure but I am doing good on
these games so that was terrifying that
was terrifying but now we've made it to
the pardon services why battle freaking
no and then van repair and then night
terrors which sounds bad but probably
five nights at Freddy's 4 or something
like that [ __ ] okay alright anyway so
that was that next up is parts and
service so thank you everybody so much
for watching
dude that was terrifying at first but
then I conquered it with my braveness so
uh thank you everybody so much for
watching there will be more of an ass
coming at you hot and heavy as fast as I
no no please stop telling me this do not
tell me this that my cam froze do not
say that how long how long has my camera
been down I have no idea so anyway I
don't know how long my camera's been
down and I don't know why that's hasn't
happened for a long time but alas here
we are god damn it okay hopefully it
wasn't too far in but if it was then you
just get to experience the dark with me
so thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye
[Music]